Here we are again with the Anom-O-Tron 6000,
our state-of-the-art simulation computer that
helps us create hyper-accurate simulations
of some of the world’s most bizarre scenarios.
Whether it’s 096 Vs Siren Head, Able Vs
Chainsaw Man, or now, perhaps our most ridiculous
match-up yet: SCP-035, the diabolical Possessive
Mask, Vs The Mask, the popular Jim Carrey
character based on the hyper-violent comic
book of the same name.
So…
What the heck are we waiting for?
Let’s crank up the machine and see what
the results are.
Somebody stop me!
“Okay, so what have we got on intake today?”
Researcher Werb asked, a tone of boredom hanging
off his every word.
“Possible anomalous entity,” his compatriot
Doctor Mahnke replied, sipping his coffee,
sounding equally as unenthused.
“Caucasian male, early thirties.
A team of our agents picked him up in…”
the Foundation doctor checked his notes.
“Some place called ‘Edge City’, real
appealing tourist spot,” he added sarcastically.
“What’s so anomalous about him?”
Werb questioned as his eyes lazily scanned
over a file Mahnke had handed him.
“Says here he’s just an ordinary bank
teller.
There’s one prior arrest on his record,
but the charges were dropped later on.
This guy’s a nobody.”
“Apparently, he was in possession of an
anomalous artifact,” came the doctor’s
reply.
He looked through the one-way glass into the
interrogation room.
Sat at the table wearing a matching pair of
hideous pajamas was a wiry, brown-haired man.
“What was it?”
Researcher Werb asked, not bothering to check
the file.
“A mask apparently,” Mahnke replied.
“This think can form a symbiotic connection
with whoever wears it.
This guy’s had it for a while, it causes
him to undergo a dramatic intensification
of his personality when he puts it on, as
well as granting him some… unusual abilities.”
“Hold on, aren’t you just describing SCP-035?”
Werb said, looking confused.
“Nope.”
The doctor responded by handing him a clear
evidence bag.
In it was a simple wooden mask, a dull, dark
greenish tint to the object.
It looked to be almost Viking in its design,
with three holes on its surface; one for the
mouth and two for the eyes.
It was hard to deny, it was completely different
from the white porcelain of SCP-035.
“What’s this guy’s name again?”
Werb sighed, looking at the scruffy, pajama-clad
man waiting for them.
“Ipkiss,” his colleague replied.
“Stanley Ipkiss.”
Meanwhile, locked up tight in a hermetically
sealed glass case, was another anomalous mask.
SCP-035 was kept under lock and key by the
Foundation, guarded constantly by a pair of
armed security officers.
One of them, Officer Riegert, had noticed
something seemed strange about the infamous
Possessive Mask today; or stranger than usual
anyway.
SCP-035 was known to compel people to wear
it if they were close enough, often through
subtle, psychic whispers.
But today, it seemed…
restless, almost agitated, like it found something
nearby to be intensely annoying.
“I already told you everything I know,”
Stanley Ipkiss sighed exhaustedly.
He’d been dragged out of bed at the crack
of dawn by strange agents and was now being
interrogated about what he knew of the wooden
Mask he’d come across floating in the river
one fateful night.
“I don’t know where it came from; I swear,
I didn’t even realize I still had it!
We threw it back in the river, but my dog
must’ve swum out and fetched it,” Stanley
explained.
“You have no idea what this thing is?
Not even from any firsthand experience, Mr.
Ipkiss?”
Doctor Mahnke asked, holding the mask up.
“Look, I did take it to a psychologist who
told me it might be Scandinavian, a representation
of some Norse night god, Loki, I think,”
he answered.
“We’re not interested in this mask as
a historical art piece,” Researcher Werb
retorted.
“Tell us what happens when you put it on.”
Stanley paused for a moment, clearly aware
he was in real trouble, but nervous about
coughing up the details to his shady captors.
With a sigh, he decided it was best to confess.
“I don’t know how it works, but whenever
you put it on it’s like it brings your deepest
desires to life.
When I wear that mask, I can do anything…
be anything,” he described, remembering
a key detail.
“But it only works at night.”
Doctor Mahnke and Researcher Werb exchanged
looks, uncertain if Ipkiss was just a lunatic
or if there was truth to what he was telling
them.
“Assemble a security team,” Mahnke sighed.
“We’ll arrange a safe environment for
you tonight, Mr Ipkiss.”
Elsewhere in the facility, Riegert and his
fellow Security Officer, Doughan, were watching
over SCP-035 with growing concern.
“What do you reckon has this thing so agitated?”
Doughan wondered aloud.
“Who knows,” Riegert sighed.
“I’ve already reported to Command, told
them 035’s in a mood.
They said to proceed as normal.”
Suddenly, as the words left his mouth, Officer
Riegert felt strange.
It was like he had been hooked by an overwhelming
urge to put the Possessive Mask on, staring
at its exaggerated white porcelain face, locked
in a tragedy frown.
He barely noticed he had reached to unlock
the door sealing the area where SCP-035 was
contained in its case, and as he stepped through,
Officer Doughan’s pleas for him to stop
barely registered.
The other officer tried in vain to pull Riegert
back as he walked towards the Possessive Mask,
only to feel his co-worker grip his shirt
and swing him face-first over and over again
into the glass case containing the anomalous
object.
His body going completely limp after being
used to break the glass, Riegert dropped Doughan
to the floor, too lost in his trance-like
state to realize he’d just killed a fellow
Foundation security officer.
He was too focused on SCP-035, as he lifted
it up and placed it over his face.
Meanwhile, Stanley Ipkiss had been brought
to a testing area, a team of security officers
standing around him.
The fact that they were all armed did little
to ease Stanley’s nerves.
Doctor Mahnke strode up to him, pulling the
green wooden mask out of the airtight bag
it had been sealed in, and handed it to Stanley.
“No funny business, Mr. Ipkiss,” the doctor
warned.
“I really can’t promise that,” Stanley
replied.
He looked at the mask in his hands, noticing
a green shimmer over the reverse side of it.
As much as he had gladly given it up, part
of him had missed wearing it.
He could already hear the low rumbling of
thunder outside as he lifted it towards his
face, feeling it almost leap out of his hands
and latch itself onto him.
The green mask eagerly became attached to
Stanley, the surface of it spreading out from
where it covered his face to wrap around his
entire head.
Around him, the guards cautiously stepped
back as they watched Stanley convulsing and
writhing about the place uncontrollably like
a man possessed.
Both Researcher Weld and Doctor Mahnke looked
at one another in wordless disbelief, before
turning back to the scene unfolding before
their eyes.
The booming noise of thunder and cracks of
lightning rang out, despite this all taking
place indoors, as Stanley Ipkiss vanished
in the center of a miniature tornado that
spun wildly around the testing area, before
slowing to a halt.
In its place stood a maniacal, wide-eyed figure,
dressed in a garish yellow zoot suit and wearing
an enormous toothed grin on his bright green
face.
“How do, fellas?”
the Mask bombastically hooted at the guards
Having been trained to deal with absurd anomalies
aplenty, the security team all defensively
raised their weapons out of a mix of instinct
and confusion.
“Yeesh, rough crowd,” the green-faced
lunatic stated to nobody; it looked like he
had turned aside, as if addressing some invisible
audience.
Outstretching both arms and one leg, the Mask
instantly zipped off, hurling around the room
in a whirlwind of absurdity, in the style
of an old Tex Avery cartoon.
The spinning, cackling combination of Stanley
Ipkiss and the magical mask weaved in between
the Foundation guards, all of whom tried in
vain to restrain him until he disappeared
out of the door.
“After him!”
Doctor Mahnke yelled with urgency in his voice.
The guards all turned to run after the Mask,
only for each one of them to trip over and
land face-first on the floor of the testing
area, as if something had tied them all up
by their ankles.
It was only as the security officers all struggled
back up to their feet that they noticed their
pants had been yanked down, leaving the Foundation’s
finest somewhat embarrassed, to say the least.
Outside the testing area, Stanley – or rather,
The Mask – had already closed the door behind
him.
Out of nowhere, he produced a series of wooden
planks and began hammering them into the doorframe,
boarding it up before speedily adding chains
and padlocks to the mix.
Sighing and exaggeratedly wiping sweat from
his brow, he turned around… only to be met
with the sight of even more SCP Foundation
guards lying in wait, their guns all trained
on him.
The Mask gave a scream of pure terror that
briefly sent his skull popping out of his
head, and his eyes shooting out of his skull,
before everything zipped right back into its
original place.
His eyes darted around at the faces of the
Foundation security, wondering how he was
going to get out of this one.
“Gee, this all seems familiar,” he said,
either to himself or his audience.
“Well, if it ain’t broken: hit it!”
In the blink of an eye, the Mask’s bright
yellow outfit had transformed, replaced by
a silk blue rumba shirt with ruffled sleeves,
white pants and a wide-brimmed black hat.
As they watched him, stood at the ready, a
few of the guards noticed the sound of…
music?
Not one of them could tell where it was coming
from, nor could they help starting to tap
their feet or bob their heads to the rhythm
of the Cuban Pete rumba.
The entire security team quickly erupted into
a full-blown dance number that anyone who
saw it couldn’t resist joining, all led
by the Mask, wildly waving maracas in the
air and singing.
Elsewhere in the facilty, Officer Riegert
was beginning to melt.
He still had SCP-035 covering his face, the
frown of the Possessive Mask conveying the
entity’s sheer discontent.
The black ooze secreting from its porcelain
surface had the unfortunate effect of corroding
and melting down anyone that wore it, dissolving
them entirely after a short period of time.
Determined, SCP-035 pushed on, piloting its
host towards a storage room.
If it remembered correctly, the SCP Foundation
had stored a number of temporary hosts for
it, mannequins that, while not human, had
enough of a humanoid shape for the Possessive
Mask to use.
Of course, after all its attempts to escape,
the Foundation had rescinded its privilege
to be granted new hosts… not that they could
stop it from taking them by force.
Using the last of Officer Riegert’s dwindling
strength, SCP-035 barged its way into the
storeroom.
Sure enough, waiting there for it was a row
of discarded mannequins.
Lifting Riegert’s hands before they had
fully melted away, the Possessive Mask used
him to place itself on a new body.
Elsewhere, not too far away in the Foundation
facility, a conga line of security officers
and research personnel was parading through
the corridors, all happily dancing and jiving
to the music despite still no one being able
to figure out where it was coming from.
Dashing away from his spot at the front of
the line, the Mask zipped around a corner,
his clothes having changed back into his signature
brightly-colored zoot suit.
“Never say no to a party!” he exclaimed,
after having danced his way to freedom.
The sound of something shuffling closer quickly
caught the Mask’s attention.
He turned around to find himself standing
green face to porcelain face with SCP-035.
“You…” the masked mannequin raised a
hollow arm, pointing a finger from its host
at Stanley.
“You bear the God of Mischief’s carving!
I could sense its presence since you arrived!”
“Stealing my look?
Nobody likes a copycat, fella!”
the Mask replied.
“Although imitation is the sincerest form
of flattery – and that’s how Jim Carrey’s
career started!” he added, exploding with
raucous laughter.
“Cease your prattling!”
SCP-035 hissed with spite.
“Say, perhaps we’re related?”
the Mask ignored it.
“We could be long-lost family!
You know, I always wanted kids of my own.
Son of the Mask, has a nice ring to it, right?”
he paused, once again turning to his unseen
audience.
“On second thoughts, maybe not.”
The SCP-035-controlled mannequin leapt forward,
gripping the Mask’s arm, causing him to
scream in shock at the advance.
His eye’s bulged out of their sockets, zooming
in on the corrosive black secretions oozing
from SCP-035.
The mannequin’s other hand started reaching
upwards, gripping his oversized green head,
as if it was trying to lift the mask right
off of Stanley’s face.
Zooming away again, he sped down the nearest
corridor, his arm stretching behind him, still
clamped in SCP-035’s grip.
Coming to a screeching halt with the comical
sound of car brakes, the Mask wobbled his
outstretched arm.
A ripple traveled all the way along the elongated
limb, as if it was made of elastic.
His wrist still being held by the mannequin
sporting the Possessive Mask, the force of
the flailing, rubbery arm was so great that
it flung SCP-035’s host body around, sending
it heat-first up into the ceiling, then plummeting
back down to the ground.
Its grip loosened, allowing the Mask to reel
back his stretchy arm, although it didn’t
return to normal length right away.
His own hand pinged back and hit him in the
face, only to start urgently trying to communicate
of its own accord.
“What’s that, boy?”
the Mask said to his hand as it started performing
a series of signals.
“Little Timmy’s stuck down a well?
You’d like Friday night’s off?
There’s a two-bit chump wearing another
mask walking menacingly down the hall towards
us?”
The hand suddenly turned the Mask’s head
to look in the right direction; sure enough,
SCP-035 was using the mannequin to walk menacing
down the hall towards him.
His elongated arm quickly returned to its
normal size, as the green-faced lunatic took
a quick draw stance, facing his oncoming adversary.
“Now, you have to ask yourself one question,”
he sneered, doing a fairly convincing impression
of a green Clint Eastwood.
“Do I feel lucky?”
With a sweep of his hand, the Mask had drawn
an enormous weapon.
The thing was a gigantic mass of different
artillery, clicking and whirring.
There were barrels on top of barrels, rockets,
and other explosives locking into place.
“Do I feel lucky?”
the Mask continued.
“Well, do ya, punk?”
SCP-035 did nothing to slow its advance, so
the Mask pulled the trigger.
Every one of his weapon’s various components
spat out a tiny flag with the word ‘bang’
written on it.
“Ah, a performance issue,” he said, doing
his aside once again.
“Not that I’m overcompensating for anything.”
Clearly growing agitated, piloting its host,
SCP-035 started charging towards the Mask.
Immediately, he spun around, becoming a tornado
of hyperactivity and whooping noises as he
sped down the adjacent corridor.
The Possessive Mask staggered after him, the
ooze leaking from the porcelain anomaly was
dripping onto the mannequin wearing it, causing
the plastic to be melted away, exposing the
flimsy metal skeleton beneath.
It knew it had to merge with a new host, find
something else to corrupt.
SCP-035 chased after the cartoonish troublemaker,
knowing that if it could catch him, he’d
be able to survive merging with it; his body,
while wearing the other mask, barely obeyed
the laws of physics, making him invulnerable
to damage, and possibly even the corrosive
substance oozing from the Possessive Mask.
As if those weren’t enough reasons, his
powers seemed virtually limitless; combined
with the green-headed lunatic, SCP-035 could
do anything.
Reaching a stop at the end of another corridor,
the Mask spun around, wearing a comically-undersized
baseball uniform.
He reached into his pocket and produced an
oversized baseball bat, then proceeded to
start hurling baseballs into the air and swatting
them as hard as he could.
As the Mask increased the speed of his swings,
a volley of hard, cork baseballs were fired
down the corridor like a barrage of bullets,
ricocheting off the walls and hitting the
oncoming SCP-035.
Each one struck its target, reeling the mannequin
but doing little much else to stop it getting
closer and closer until…
With an almighty swing, the Mask brought his
bat crashing into SCP-035 with enough force
to send the Possessive Mask and its host careening
down the corridor.
It sailed through the air, bursting through
a wall, then flew into a research lab, tearing
a huge hole in the next wall as it kept going.
Finally, it came crashing out of one last
wall; the outer wall of the facility, and
dropped multiple stories to the ground outside.
Changing costumes back to his classic suit
and dashing after SCP-035, the Mask passed
through all the holes his adversary had left
in the multiple walls it had crashed into.
He screeched to a halt again and paused after
getting through the outer wall, only to realize
after a moment that he was hovering in mid-air,
not standing on anything.
Reaching into his suit pocket, the Mask pulled
out a sign on a stick, with a single word
written on it: ‘yikes’.
He plummeted down to ground level, landing
with such an immense crash that his body cracked
into the asphalt below.
It left a perfect outline of him imprinted
in the ground, causing the Mask to go completely
pancake-flat head to toe.
Suddenly, before he could peel himself up
off the ground and go back to being three-dimensional,
SCP-035 staggered to its host’s feet, and
pinned the Mask down.
“Finally!”
it growled.
“I’ve caught you!
I’ve won!
Your power is mine, once I’ve combined with
you I will be able to ravage this world.
I’m going to fuse to your face, then I’ll
start with decimating those wretches that
imprisoned me, the Foundation will fall and
then so will the rest of their precious world.”
Forcefully, the mannequin’s hand wrenched
the Mask off the ground, but as SCP-035 turned
to look at what it had hoped to be its next
host…
well, let’s say the tragedy frown carved
into its porcelain face had never been more
appropriate.
It wasn’t holding the Mask, it was holding
a life-size cardboard cut-out, a photo of
the Mask grinning out from one side.
Enraged, the Possessive Mask tore the decoy
in half with its mannequin’s hands.
“Hey, Pachuco,” said a cartoonish voice
from right behind it.
“Did you miss me?”
The Mask had reappeared, for real this time,
grinning with his huge teeth, clearly getting
a kick out of having somebody to torment.
SCP-035, on the other hand, had been getting
increasingly irritated by all the wacky cartoon
antics.
With all the aggression it could channel through
its mannequin host, it gripped the Mask by
the throat, his eyes bulging out of his head
again.
“Gee, no need to get all choked up over
it,” he gagged.
“You are so tiresome!”
the Possessive Mask yelled, having finally
run out of patience.
“You know what?
I won’t merge with you; I should just kill
you and put an end to your buffoonery!
Let me take this off you first though,”
its mannequin fingers started to hook into
the mask’s seam at the back of his bald,
green head.
“Wait, wait!”
the Mask begged, putting both his hands up
in surrender.
“At least give me a final request, huh?
Mask to mask?”
Before the Possessive Mask could respond,
the Mask had swept it off its dissolving mannequin
feet.
He started to spin it around in a wild, over
the top dance number, bopping and swinging
to a tune that seemed to be coming from nowhere.
The longer it went on for, the more and more
of SCP-035’s host body started to dissolve
away, until the mannequin finally wasted away.
All that was left was a bubbling pile of black
goo on the ground with the Possessive Mask
laying in the middle.
The Mask chuckled, noticing the fumes trailing
upwards into the air as the corrosive substance
melted away the last of SCP-035 host.
“Talk about sssmokin’!”
Now go and check out “WHAT IF SCP-343 WORE
SCP-035?”
and “The Whole Story!
- What if SCP-096 Wore SCP-035?”
for more adventures from the evil SCP-035!